[Music]
on this Tuesday night from Edmonton the
ucp's victory Premier Danielle Smith's
promise I cannot under any circumstances
allow these contemplated Federal
policies to be inflicted upon albertans
her loss of key seats to the NDP now is
not the time to let up now is the time
to step up I'll speak one-on-one with
Premier Smith what can you say to
reassure those moderate conservatives
on alert the Raging wildfires rattling
Nova scotia's nerves
and fresh claims how Beijing allegedly
targeted the former Federal conservative
leader
[Music]
Donna Frieza reporting tonight from
Edmonton
good evening from Alberta's Capital it
was Danielle Smith's first test in a
provincial election since becoming
leader of the United conservative party
and she passed Smith will stay on as
Premier new Democrats won 38 there will
be recounts in two Calgary ridings where
the margins were razor
here are the numbers the UCP 149 of 87
seats the new Democrats won 38 there
will be recounts in two Calgary writings
where the margins were razor thin and
where both parties one revealed how
politically polarized Alberta Remains
the NDP swept all the seats in Edmonton
winning every riding there rural Alberta
is the opposite almost all blue in
Calgary the NDP flipped several seats
booting out some UCP cabinet ministers
and winning more seats overall than they
did in the last election
I'm very pleased that we we will be
welcoming at least 10 more mlas to our
caucus
who will form part of the largest
official opposition this province has
ever seen in his history
[Applause]
Danielle Smith did win a majority but
it's a slim majority and its base is
rural that will affect who she picks for
her cabinet and possibly how she governs
Heather York's West is with me here
Heather yes several former cabinet
ministers were defeated last night in
tightly contested races across the big
cities including the former deputy
Premier Casey maddu and former Health
and Justice ministers Jason koffing and
Tyler shandro though chandra's race is
being subject to a recount three other
former ministers from the Calgary area
also failed to hold on to their seats
most of the new UCP caucus does come
from areas outside the big city creating
a government and Province divided across
Urban rural lines
for the people of Wetaskiwin a little
city south of Edmonton the morning after
Alberta's election is a beautiful sunny
day it's good for Alberta River stable
as being a local business owner I think
now we've got a good direction to keep
Alberta going on the path to move
forward
S I am and what's what about that part
resonates with you
oh
I think their fiscal spending is
I think they can keep it under control
across rural Alberta the UCP has found
overwhelming support picking up 37 of a
possible 41 seats enough to propel
Danielle Smith's team to another mandate
even after losing every seat in Edmonton
and about half the seats in Calgary I
was hoping the other party would have
won I didn't want to really
Daniel Smith in it just for trust
reasons I don't she switches back and
forth so often so it really is the the
tale of two Alberta's and somebody has
got to reconcile with that a task that
falls to not only Alberta's new premier
but the province's new opposition leader
as well now is the time for us to do the
work that has been asked of us it is my
honor to serve as your leader and it is
my privilege to continue to serve as
leader of the official opposition
the Alberta NDP leader failed to form
government but Rachel notley says she
has no plans to step down as leader
anytime soon her caucus elected more
than a dozen new members including Jody
calahoo Stonehouse the first First
Nations woman to be elected to the
Alberta legislature and Rhiannon Hoyle
the first black woman to become an
Alberta MLA
the new faces representing Alberta after
one of the most divisive election races
this province has ever seen
now Edmonton's mayor is among those who
are concerned that this city of a
million people have has no
representation at the Alberta
legislation interestingly this has
happened before back in the 90s under
then Premier Ralph Klein at the time the
mayor brokered a deal to have one of the
liberal mlas across the floor in
exchange for cabinet posts but it is
unlikely we'll see that kind of deal
happen in this case okay Heather York's
West thank you with me from Calgary's
Mercedes Stevenson Mercedes Danielle
Smith faces a strong opposition in the
NDP lots of people who didn't vote for
her could that be a moderating influence
on her
well Donna it may be less the NDP that's
the moderating force on her and more
perhaps her own caucus she's going to be
pulled in two directions on the one hand
she has at the promises and the alliance
that she's made with some of these
Alberta first people uh who are much
further to the right were talking about
for example the Coots blockade in
favorable terms anti-vaxxers those who
oppose the Mandate and on the other hand
she has the moderate conservatives who
voted really more for the UCP than for
her and the biggest danger historically
to conservatives at both the federal and
provincial level in recent years has
actually been from within their own
caucus so she has to find a way to keep
both sides happy feel both sides that
she is listening to them and while
she'll have to reach out and have an
olive branch to the NDP She is safe in
terms of a government for four years
whether she's safe for later is four
years will depend in part on that caucus
management
and she's been congratulated by prime
minister Justin Trudeau and the
conservative leader Pierre pauliev who
endorsed her what's the relationship
with the federal conservatives going to
look like
well for the conservatives this is both
good and bad it's good because it tells
them there's an appetite to elect
conservative governments and that the
kind of populism that per poliov
exhibits is also exhibited by Danielle
Smith also someone who endorsed the
Convoy at the time and that that can be
elected and those positions by moderate
conservatives if perhaps there is a
fiscal platform that they are happy with
on the other hand the risk to Pierre
poliov is that Justin Trudeau will tie
to try to tie any of her more
controversial statements or policies to
Pierre pauliev and that may not play
well for him in places like Ontario
well Smith sounded pretty combative
Mercedes in Her speech last night about
the Trudeau government here's a clip
what do you make of that Mercedes
well Donna I think that this is what do
you make of that Mercedes
well Donna I think that this is Roderick
that the premier feels is effective it
establishes her as an Alberta First as
she likes to say in albertan's First
Premier but at the end of the day she's
taking a softer tone with prime minister
Justin Trudeau when you and I spoke to
her today she does want to collaborate
it seems but both she and Justin Trudeau
can benefit from some of that political
tension that comes from a relationship
like this
okay Mercedes Stevenson in Calgary thank
you now to those wildfires in Nova
Scotia hundreds of homes and structures
are damaged or destroyed conditions are
very dry and there's a province-wide ban
on open fires yet six new fires started
just last night
do not burn uh six illegal Burns
reported just last night is Just
mind-boggling so no Burning uh for for
God's sake stop burning stop flicking
your cigarette Bops out your car window
just stop it uh our resources are
stretched incredibly thin right now
fighting existing fires
the good news the tantalan fire near
Halifax has not grown but thousands of
people are still out of their homes the
wind could push the fire back to areas
that have already burned Mike Armstrong
is in the area tonight
thank you
Crews were out at first light ready for
another day of battle as they prepared
this was the sun rising through the
smoke of a fire that's forced thousands
out of their homes I didn't think it
would ever go through like it has the
Smiths left their home Sunday afternoon
they're staying with their daughter this
morning they were waiting at the
roadblock to their Community desperate
to get back to check on their cat they
left too quickly to grab it the Flames
arrived too suddenly they just shot
right from the ground and started
shooting right up into the trees and it
was unbelievable one second there was no
fire in the next city yep the heavy
heavy smoke came in and then seconds
behind it the fire was there
now few have seen their homes or even
had news since escaping Sunday when this
was the last thing you saw it's hard to
have confidence about what you'll go
back to
it's bad praying everybody's okay and
the house is still there we don't we
don't know
but they're living through the grants
say it was the uncertainty just not
knowing if your house is still there or
not that's that's the worst part but now
we know so
you feel way better wait way way better
this map the city is giving people a
better idea of what's happened on the
ground an updated map shows an orange
section what it calls an area of
significant impact
now one challenge for firefighters right
now is hot spots smaller fires still
burning that could spread there's also
the issue of what's called reburn when
the fire goes through a specific area it
cures those fuels so those fuels that
haven't been consumed the first time
that that fire goes over now are ready
to burn
fires Force animals out of the woods
Woods there are new rules to prevent
more situation is so dry the province is
Banning not just outdoor fires but
hiking camping fishing all activity in
forests
like Armstrong Global News Halifax
meteorologist Anthony Farnell is
watching the conditions Anthony why did
these fires take off so fast and what's
in the forecast
well Donna this all started on Sunday
when it was a combination of Gusty winds
record heat and record low humidity but
it actually goes back in fact since
early February this entire region has
seen less snow and less rain than normal
in places like Halifax it's about 50
percent of average over the course of
that period and lately we've had a lot
more of these big high pressure systems
that have meant subsidence sinking air
warming temperatures another surge of
warmth on the way over the next couple
of days highs could top 30 degrees
relative humidity in the 20 to 30
percent range which when combined with
wind and sunshine really dries out the
vegetation and can lead to extreme
forest fire risk but there is relief on
the way 21 degrees Friday with showers
and then a much cooler and at times wet
pattern lingering into early next week
Donna
okay Global News meteorologist Anthony
Farnell thanks in New Brunswick people
who had to leave their homes because of
a fire near St Andrews are allowed to go
home that place is still considered out
of control though Crews have made some
progress containing and protecting homes
more than 50 firefighters are attacking
it on the ground and at least one home
has been destroyed officials say that
fire was started by an ATV the entire
Province also remains under a burn ban
former conservative leader Aaron O'Toole
has outlined what he calls a
sophisticated campaign by the Chinese
government to Target him and undermine
Canadian democracy Canada's spy agency
briefed O'Toole about beijing's efforts
to tarnish his reputation and spread
misinformation during the last election
O'Toole says it underscores the need for
a public inquiry turia isri reports
Aaron O'Toole is outlining how the
Chinese Communist Party allegedly
targeted him and how in his view the
Canadian government failed to stop it
thank you madam speaker it's a point of
privilege the former conservative leader
spoke in the house and offered a rare
level of detail about beijing's tactics
The Briefing from ceases confirmed to me
what I expected suspected for quite some
time
that my parliamentary caucus
and myself were the target of a
sophisticated misinformation and voter
suppression campaign Canada's spy agency
informed the Ontario MP on Friday he's
been singled out because of his hard
line on China O'Toole would not go into
specifics but says the Chinese
government paid and directed groups
operating in Canada to spread
misinformation in an effort to discredit
and undermine him it was incredibly
frustrating O'Toole's former campaign
manager says the party raised its
concerns but they went nowhere the
security establishment was telling us
that there's gaps in the legislation so
what are those gaps and how do we plug
this to make sure the stuff does not
happen again ceases has briefed at least
three MPS the Chinese government has
allegedly targeted the former Governor
General ruled out holding a public
inquiry but is recommending opposition
leaders be granted top secret clearance
to review the intelligence that led to
his conclusion we don't need more people
to keep secrets we need more people
telling the truth he is choosing to not
get briefed up on the actual facts of
the matter O'Toole is one of the many
calling for a public inquiry Colin
Johnston's recommendation offensive
O'Toole is resigning from his seat this
summer ceases has warned him he will
remain a target of the Chinese
government long after leaving politics
Taria esri Global News Ottawa
you are looking at the downtown Calgary
Skyline we're back in a moment
[Music]
Russia launched another aerial assault
on Ukraine early this morning the third
in 24 hours
in kieva high-rise building was damaged
at least one person died four others
were injured Ukraine says its air
defense system destroyed more than 20
drones from Russia he has faced a
barrage of drone attacks this month
there were drone strikes in Moscow too
they cause little damage but people were
forced to flee their homes in at least
three residential Towers it's believed
to be the first time civilians were
targeted since Russia lost launched its
full-scale invasion of Ukraine Russian
president calls it a terrorist act
Ukraine says it had nothing directly to
do with it
uniting Alberta ahead I speak with
Premier Danielle Smith
welcome back to Alberta with me from
Calgary is Premier Danielle Smith
Premier Smith congratulations
thanks Donna
you know you said in your speech last
night your oath is to serve all
albertans no matter how they voted you
were shout out shot out of Edmonton
though you lost seats to the NDP in
Calgary including some of your top
cabinet ministers and you did run some
pretty negative attack ads during the
campaign is that all really behind you
now
well I would say that I was on the
receiving end of a pretty negative
advertising campaign for not just the
the duration of the election campaign
but for several months we've got almost
53 percent of the vote and so I think
people wanted to we've made on public
health care and of course our approach
to Public Safety and mental health and
addiction the next big push of course is
making sure that everybody get has
access to a family practitioner and so
I'm really hopeful that we'll be able to
work with the the front line to be able
to address those needs of albertans the
first policy point you made in your
acceptance speech was that you're not
going to raise taxes without a
referendum where are you going to raise
the money to improve things like health
care and education
one of the things that we discovered is
that by reducing tax rates you could
actually increase Revenue we brought our
tax rate from 12 down to eight percent
on our job creators and investment
flowed into our Province we now have
more corporate income tax than we have
in our history and that's going to be
our message is Alberta's open for
business Alberta is calling we want to
continue to have jobs and investment in
people coming here because as we grow
our economy that grows our revenues
which will allow us to continue to meet
those priorities of albertans and I'm
looking forward to that continuing and I
think that's what albertans voted for
last night the previous UCP leader Jason
Kenney was ousted by the party last year
how confident are you that you can keep
the United conservative party United
look I mean getting a 53 mandate was was
pretty exciting for me it means that the
majority of albertans Love The Vision
that we put forward I think we're going
to put together a really diverse cabinet
that's going to represent the interests
of all albertans and and I think people
will will Judge Me based on not only the
seven months I've had to govern but also
as I continue going forward I think
people are pretty excited about what
we're going to be able to do over the
next few years have you heard from the
folks that take back Alberta such as
David Parker who you know takes credit
for getting you into the leadership
I no I uh I have heard from all kinds of
members I've been on the campaign Trail
now for over a year because I've been
doing my leadership and then it was a
by-election and then of course we've had
the general election uh and I'm I'm at
the moment I'm uh got I've got a new
mandate I've got a new job and that's
the the job to be Premier for all
albertans and that's what I'm focused on
doing but you know take back Alberta
takes credit for getting you into the
leadership I'm just asking if you've
heard from them if they said good job
Danielle
[Music]
you know what leadership contests are
one thing but then when you get a
mandate from the people you've got to
govern for all albertans I mentioned
that last night in my speech and I meant
it and it's part of the reason why we're
going to continue focusing on the things
that I know I got a mandate for and that
was um moving Alberta forward and making
sure that our economy stays strong so
that we can address the priorities of
albertans that's that's what I'm going
to be laser focused on doing
well there are moderate conservatives in
Alberta who did vote NDP who worry about
who is controlling the UCP now who fear
it could be moving too far right what
can you say to reassure those moderate
conservatives I I think what has
actually happened in Alberta is that the
the left has Consolidated around a
single party which is the NDP so we're
now really a two-party Province and that
means that we're going to face a pretty
Fierce and unified opposition and that's
how democracy Works they're we're going
to put our ideas forward they're going
to test them and hopefully we'll be able
to make better decisions as a as a
result
I know you spoke to the Prime Minister I
think today how did that conversation go
thank you so for the work that he has
done with us on helping to fight fight
fires we've had our worst uh Spring
Forest Fire season in our history over a
million hectares burn I also told him
that I want to reset our relationship
and hope that we can move forward
together with an aspiration of being
carbon neutral by 2050 and work together
to make sure that there are no decisions
made at the federal level that will
impair or impact our oil natural gas
industry and so we'll we'll see how that
relationship unfolds but I did let him
know that I think we're all better off
when Alberta is allowed to thrive
because when we do well the rest of the
country does well and that's that's the
spirit that I'm going into this new
mandate with
all right Premier Danielle Smith thank
you
thanks Donna
she is down but not out next how a BC
woman won one of the world's most
bizarre races
you're looking at Downtown Edmonton from
the University of Alberta we're back in
a moment
[Music]
there's a weird thing they do in the UK
every year a cheese Rolling competition
down an extremely steep hill and this
time a woman from British Columbia won
it but she paid a big price
foreign
Delaney Irving got medical treatment
right away she has a concussion but said
afterwards she regrets nothing
first question how are you I'm good now
that I remember it I'm good you took
hell of a tumble did I yeah so what do
you remember of the race
um I remember running and then I hurt my
head and then I woke up in the tent
makes it feel to be the winner it feels
so good
so the question is are you going to come
back to you yeah kind of hit her after
all that she goes home with bragging
rights and a seven pound wheel of cheese
that is global national for this Tuesday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
is Ranch Country near stavely Alberta an
hour's Drive south of Calgary thanks for
watching nitu garcher will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I'll see you
again on Thursday bye-bye
[Music]